so advice to people on being caught in
two worlds because the reality of being
here is that that may be the case for a
decade for some people maybe even more
and at some point they will cross over
and they'll be hosting parties and for
some it may not happen but on keeping
your mind right
and keeping your work ethic right well
that's that's difficult I mean it's like
it's like training I used to run you
know as a runner and that that
discipline of that constant was really
important you know and I would run no
matter if I was tired and it's that same
work ethic that you need is writing
because they see so many writers who say
huh and it's difficult I understand I
tell some some writers though I just did
a 10-hour day in there like ten hours
ago we'll have to because I have an
assignment and it's due and and I have
the luxury that's my job thank God you
know now when I had a day job only once
in my life for two years I worked at a
law firm I had to come home from a full
day work I was an assistant and then at
six o'clock make dinner and then right
until midnight and then go to bed 7 a.m.
go to that job it was having two jobs at
once and then on the weekends people
would say oh come on do this and that I
say well I have to write write what are
you talking to my said well and it was
it was terribly exhausting and I can see
how it can chip away you know and at you
especially if you have a family and a
lot of different concerns pulling at you
that's why you have to really close the
door and say this is my time and had it
cannot be interrupted and that it is
hard to do but you really have to stay
discipline and also I think you have to
have the fire and burning passion to
really want it more than anything else
because you know I never I never put an
expiration date on my dreams and I
remember people say well it was a dinner
one time friend of my brothers and he
said well what if you don't make it by
30 and I was like 30 and I said well I
don't know what's 30 and they ut2 him he
was projecting his fear upon me and I go
hi this is open-ended you know I'm sorry
but
you know and that's good and bad because
you don't want to fool yourself like
you're saying we're ten years and you
have nothing I mean I think at a certain
point if you've really exhausted all of
your abilities
and nothing's happened you might
consider something that maybe writings
not for you maybe this pursuit of a
career is not for you and it's a choice
no one's forcing you to write
screenplays it's a dream you know it was
my dream since I was 11 years old so am
I gonna achieve it
am I gonna achieve it at a level that I
want because I like when I worked in the
restaurant while I was going to film
school I knew people or actors they said
well it's not worth it for me if I'm not
like Brad Pitt and I said oh really
so you think you're just going to fall
into it and be a list now most working
actors or the you know the co-star
character actors work all their lives
the leading person leading man leading
woman have to carry the film and how
many you know I mean it's sorry I just
you look at it it's like and plus as you
as you get older you you look at it
differently and you say well I'm I'm
blessed to get up in the morning and do
what I love for a living and get paid
for it and see it you know see it end up
somewhere and people respond to it
negatively or positively that's it you
know yes continue to strive for more and
other projects and different things but
it's hard and but the important thing
too is to have people around you that
support your endeavor because I've lost
friendships and I've lost relationships
with people who said well and they drew
a line in the sand and they said and I
was like well it's not a good thing to
do and what about the last X number of
years I've been doing this you're just
gonna throw help me throw that away you
know the the lack of understanding about
how much filmmaking and writing was such
a part of my being almost that other
creative endeavors like drawing and
things like that but but this is like
Who I am and to have someone with you
not understand that it's really you know
and that's the hardest part that so many
elements just like in making a film
so many elements have to go together and
all click the same way with forging a
career and as you've interviewed many
different people everybody will tell you
a different story about how they
quote-unquote made it and I was doing a
seminar recently and someone asked the
question about making it and I said well
I think I don't know if you ever make it
I said I think getting your next job is
making it and continuing to stay in the
game is making it you know there's
nothing guaranteed if you're on a TV
show the show's gonna end then you have
to get up and we're like gypsies find
another job I have a movie shooting
right now in Los Angeles when that ends
I mean luckily I have a few things
already going set up you know job wise
you have to find your next job you know
it's just it's just the case but after
it's it's difficult but you know no one
said it was going to be easy
before we wrap up on this topic I just
want to ask going back to that day that
you're working this shift at wherever it
was the top of Mulholland or wherever it
was Beverly Hills okay and you're you're
let's suppose so you've you've broken
down the event you're driving down this
mountain or wherever it may be not a
mountain what's going through your mind
your names and Friday why I stopped at
the newsstand before the job and picked
up a pile of varieties you know because
you have to and reread it and I wasn't
on the cover the company was on the
cover but I wasn't like peach 13 with a
paragraph how they discovered me right
so it's so you know it's so nice to be
discovered and I'm here you know pouring
coffee for you know these people it was
it was freak because there was a fear
that like that was like somehow it was a
big fraud and and it was never gonna
happen even though it was terrible I
mean it was it was hard to to really
lock in and then you get home and it's
like very depressing you're like there's
no crowd cheering there's no II like wow
but then being pragmatic saying well I
have to pay bills and there's no
embarrassment about doing a job that you
have to do because that job allowed me
to continue to stay in the game now yes
the the movie was optioned
as movie options goes there's not for a
lot of money sometimes and so and then
the movie developed 18 months it was in
development with me so you're talking
about and that script was seven years
after I wrote it so it took seven years
from when I finished it to when it
finally found the company and was made
not all scripts happen that way you know
but I'm talking about a spec and so this
long process with a lot of fear that can
be involved but yeah it was it was you
know but I always look back on these
stories not at the time maybe and say
this will be a good story for the book
someday or to tell someone you know how
these things happen you know there's a
reason why I think we go through
everything is to either learn something
and if we do maybe pay it forward and
saying hey you know and that's kind of
like my reasoning for the book is to try
to pay it forward and saying you know I
went through all these crazy knocks and
these pitfalls and you will to maybe
more maybe less
but maybe if you had zig and zag and
it'll help you a little easier you know
but it's all difficult for all of us
because we also have to sit in front of
the blank page you know that's where
we're equals
as screenwriters you know
you